[Music]
you guys know what the Library of
Congress is live with what they've been
doing is archiving every like book ever
it and every piece of literature and
they revealed a couple months ago that
they've also been archiving every tweet
that's ever been oh they are did not the
same hard drives as the best literature
ever written so I wanna yeah you should
all be terrified yeah I want to play
this game on what's the game well how
does it work I'm gonna read you a quote
and you have to tell me if it's
something from a great piece of
literature or if it's something I found
on Twitter okay okay so I'll read you a
quote okay you have to guess and there's
nothing at stake I have no gift for you
it's my life go ahead it is not in the
Stars to hold our destiny but in
ourselves okay that's come on not in the
stores to hold our destiny great great
great great that's Shakespeare that's
correct yeah that's right I went yeah
it's good right it's not as stars don't
wanna continue continue second one
surrounded by milfs at Taco Bell
[Applause]
I'm gonna go with that William Faulkner
yeah I was gonna say Emily Dickens and
her tacos
ha
[Music]